cela fait maintenant près d'un an qu'il
a pris sa retraite il dessinait comme un
dieu chaque feuille qu'il touchait se
transformer en véritable oeuvre d'art
mais aujourd'hui pour votre cru plus
grand plaisir il a du mal à parler
hockey salut je mangeais supérieur parce
qu'il sert à rien 2016 c'est tout
électronique un clown au nez sur
quickdraw c'est un jeu fait par google
google la famille toi même tu sais ce
qui me paye tous les mois merci 1 c'est
parti on va devoir dessiner saut c'est
quoi ce mois je vais le film je connais
une 6 ha oui aux caisses participantes y
voit une montagne il voit une étoile
horaires plane
il voit un avion il métal locaux je peux
reset éventuellement à l'état ici moi je
la cite six mais merde quoi ça je vois
zigzag non non la cie comme ça aux prix
ils coulent montée quasi bon bah je sais
pas mais attends mais comment tu vas
présenter d'ici à mai oui moi je pensais
à la scie sauteuse je pensais à celle là
non avec je crois que je joue vraiment
trop jeu vidéo j'imaginais à ben
chouikha en fait voilà il m'a demandé de
faire une si j'ai fait un show week-end
dessine une main très très simple on
fait le poignet ce assez large et un
ticket pour le pousse les quatre autres
audois oh je sais c'est une main et un
an il avait marqué alors c'est bon j'ai
réussi dessine une barbe c'est très
simple on va reproduire ça
it s béart watch que j'ai de la barbe
que je sais dessinée de la barbe ok ça
vous va baisser d'un cookie très simple
or prévient cotter tous il voit une
potée tôt blueberry à ouattara s'est
heurtée à une patate mais je sais moi
qui est tombée drue du pata décide un
pantalon pas bien sûr ici le hors champ
de lier un chandelier voilà tel but
plaisir tâche vraiment le dessin de base
une voiture là on va mettre un petit peu
de 3d ça va être al dente
[Musique]
j'ai fait une soucoupe volante lui vaut
un burger donc j'ai pas trop comment de
prendre l'avantagé 1 spécial a reconnu
cinq de tes dessins mais il a vu autre
chose dont l'un d'eux il a vu un
bracelet ensuite un cercle et ensuite en
ville mais c'est évident que c'est une
si google est évident regarder cette
ressemblance n'est rarement vu une si
aussi bien fait là yogan alors tu as
demandé de faire une fleur la fleur de
l'enfant c'est quoi les deux petites
feuilles en bas de celle ci la petite
tige et les pétales ici garden je vois
gardonne mais non de la coupe de ta
grand mère ça si je fais ça n'enlèverait
ice cream et non un ventilateur mais
c'est un peu comme une fleur hop hop hop
hop
mais tout dans la grille qui protège ta
tête coiffée et le pied qui tient le
ventilateur il a trouvé il a trouvé un
bracelet je vais te faire un bras ça
c'est les poils que tu es arrêté de ton
père et ça c'est bon tu vois un
téléphone une clarinette mais son rythme
et se créer bon boulot et je te parie
qu'ils embauchent fera mieux que ça sent
les gones est une star taylor
donc c'est finalement comme africaine
commune faire comme un ventilateur ou un
film a déjà trois fois pourtant un truc
différent une moto je m'attache pas vous
mentir je m'appliquais
tess motorbike jetons finir à fulham
éduqués pour qu'elle connaisse des trucs
par contre pour être poli ça ça ira
et puis personne faut jamais eu le
meilleur contre mes enfants ils vont
exploser de rire mais il a tout trouvé
sauf ma fleur qui ressemble à une
carotte face reste est mon étoile et l'a
reconnu il voyait un avion aussi dans
mon étoile à regarder on peut voir les
autres mecs ont dessiné une étoile
attend lui a toujours pokémon il l'a
fait star il omet à huy hà technique
d'enfants d'âgés pas pensé ok un bouchon
de bouteille
un bouchon à vis et où un bouchon de
champagne en liège c'est une question
importante imposée
ok bouchon c'est sa pop et lie à la
bouteille là c'est une bouteille d'eau à
temps je t'aime je t'aime vite fait
voilà tu connais pas non mais un bouchon
c'est un bouchon un bush là tu as
noiseau j'aimerais bien réussir un
dessin un jour je pense déjà faut
commencer par l'ale c'est comme quand tu
coupes le poulet chez toi midi j'aurai
pas de faire des comparaisons c'est
chiant il nomme ites burt
il a et roubaix il est roi mais j'ai pas
fini d s'était rendu à tous qui l'attend
j'ai fait les l'a reconnu il faut faire
un nuage
ah ben là c'est un petit peu comme la
fleur ventilateur est un finalement à
pas se mentir
voilà mais il peut te demander de
décider un micro tu fais juste un motif
qui se la pète comme pour la fleur de
l'âge et tout va trouver c'est bien
qu'il y ait pas de belges v10 abusent un
trombone c'est plus dur que ça n'en a
l'air alors maintenant avancer ça or un
trombone mais comment on fait trop beau
c'est un trombone un peuplier qu'on a
joué avec ont accroché l'ac et autres
passeurs pour lui voler son journal
intime
aa c'est trop cher c'est comme par
exemple un bon c'est bien là bas si trop
molle il a dit paperclip c'est là c'est
bien la même chose que trombone à notre
voie de l'instrument pour aller faire un
air butin mais séoul avait requis il
avait reconnu quand même le trombone
comme je le voyais donc aller à l'essai
un skull mec jamais été pour dessiner
devant hockey selon hypoxie popsicle
sais pas s'il voit un popsicle qu'est ce
que c'est un popsicle sans déconner même
même google lui même c'est pas il se
passe que c'est une rondelle de hockey
alors avec une perspective 3d assez beau
nom mais toujours à la ramasse les jets
fabas les merde merde rien la rondelle
vers la rondelle
elle est là elle est la horde d'or
[ __ ] une carte datant commenté abbaoui
d'un film d'ailleurs me souviens c'était
comme ça et là tu fais juste genre des
petites plantes pour des petites
feuilles voilà vos reer et fort un oeil
un deuil commençait un deuil
enfin un rond et qu'un point de vente au
québec manon et voyagea y voyait truc du
hockey me sers nous y eut dit pourquoi
tu vois il ya gaouette alors que j'ai pu
j'ai pas compris il avait par contre si
on fait quoi
à toi d'où tu reconnais lui et tu
reconnais pas le mien ce foutage de
gueule non j'avoue ok pardon allez cette
france qu'on sente pas ce qu'on veut si
sur six ventilateurs et voilà les
ventilateurs qui a trait à la fin de sa
route il a tout est là d'où lui vient
marquer le nuage la flore tous les trucs
qui [ __ ] en fait c'est une clôture une
barrière une palissade housse avec dur
ça va être très très très dur ah non je
sais on va faire les palissades
américaine porter haut le flambeau à
l'ouest à un canot attend une potée toi
avec ta cote est aussi un canon mais ça
se voit non mais là par contre ça c'est
un canot tiens regarde cette fille elle
est canon mdr un canon à canon c'est
quoi c'est ça c'est ça ça c'est un canon
bimla ya un bout l'équipe a préparé y
toucher un an je peux partager je me
protège et qu'est ce qui fait passer les
oraux alors [ __ ] les gens au pad
renoir sont payés voilà qui est fait en
plus si la misère sont lents et bien moi
j'en suis fort de cette véritable vidéo
exceptionnelle sponsorisé par le louvre
c'est faux n'hésitez pas là mais ça vous
a plu [ __ ] google fête des
intelligences artificielles très très
forte
c'est très très fort je pense pas qu'il
intéresse artificielle capable de
reconnaître des dessins puis dominer le
monde
mais dans le doute ait un geyser les
réactions non non non c'est quoi ça va
être quoi les réactions c'est moche
merci